vous adorez faire des blagues mais très
bien et bien bon soir sur canal + à
trouver je pense notre maître incontesté
à tous en la matière il s'appelle houba
butler il est anglais et regardez ce
qu'il a fait il publie sur le média vice
une farce énorme
il prend sa propre cabane comme décor
pour créer un restaurant qui n'existent
que sur internet mais ses amis écrivent
de faux éloge du restaurant fake donc
sur tripadvisor pendant ce temps lui il
refuse toutes les réservations une à une
et résultat en six mois seulement le
restaurant passe de 18 millièmes de
londres à premier sur tripadvisor des
questions sur ses sites keynote et qui
nous disaient les ventes l hôtel où
aller dans tel restaurant où elle voit
là parce qu'il ya des avis positifs qui
seront en nombre et c'est là vraiment ça
remet en cause le bas ce sur quoi on se
base qu'en tant que consommateur non non
mais après lui c'est vraiment un roi
c'est le roi du fait que c'est un peu
comme thibault qui nous fait part depuis
10 ans que sa vraie chroniqueur c'est
bon un truc qu'il est plusieurs à savoir
un nom de madoff
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que c'est tout simplement une
grosse blague potache où est ce que vous
imaginez que derrière il veut ils
veulent dénoncer quelque chose au moins
ils dénoncent vraiment quelque chose et
il dénonce le fawe wallace et ses sites
où absolument tout le monde peut écrire
n'importe quoi en faisant croire qu'un
restaurant est absolument un goût faible
alors que c'est totalement la verse et
cette espèce de vendre vendanges
vengeance qu'on peut avoir parfois c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que maintenant je
crois que je vais m'arrêter là on est
d'accord
caroline qui arrive à moi je me dis de
pouvoir glander à ce pont non mais je
pense qu'il a érigé ans mais c'est
carrément boulot quoi maintenant son
boulot c'est ça après il sort un bouquin
bruit on le type 1 non mais franchement
je trouve ça assez malin c'est assez
bien fait je me serais la première est
le fait de ne pas pouvoir aller dans ce
restaurant week ont réservé il disait
que c'était complet je trouve que sa
mort est tellement énervée j'aurais
tellement voulu y aller que je pense
qu'on va tout le monde à tout s'est fait
prendre en photo au piège on s'est très
mal
il s'attaque aussi de tous les gens qui
prennent en photo leurs repas dans les
restaurants et donc il a bien montré là
la différence qui avait entre le vrai le
faux et c'est à moi pour moi c'est un
prince de l'humour je veux le rencontrer
très bien l'écouter c'est sur votre les
à noël on va parler nourriture tous les
jeux thibault ça me fait sourire qu'on
rigole de cette histoire alors que
personne ne s'est fait avoir on peut
tout biaisé aujourd'hui c'est fait avoir
dans le quartier ils savent bien qui a
pas de restaurants là et personne qui
fait pointer en attendant pendant un
quart d'heure là ils ont créé cette
histoire juste pour montrer les dérives
de un peu la société actuelle mais
personne s'est fait avoir
caroline donnerait jamais appelé passera
tout compris que la supercherie
attendait il il a aussi causé des
dizaines et des dizaines et des dizaines
de coups de fil mais j'attends devrait
pas suffire
les imams et les chants et chansons et
n'a pas assez travaillé c'est pour ça
allez on vous avez des actions mois on
vous a posé la question sur twitter est
ce que vous faites confiance aux sites
d'avis sur internet
oui à 38% non à 60 2 % visiblement les
consommateurs sont quand même de plus en
plus éclairé est il prêt ils ne prennent
pas pour argent comptant ce qu'ils
lisent sur les différents sites